is it possible for writers starting out
today to have the same type of tv
writing career that you had in terms of
writers nowadays having the same kind of
career i had uh no they could they can't
really because television has changed so
so much well when i uh started out i
started writing in the late 70s and
still going strong today i've been very
lucky um
back then
most shows
had freelance slots so in other words
for instance when i was a producer on
sliders we had a 22 episode order for
that season and 11 of those would be
freelance slots so every day we were
taking pitches from writers and we knew
we'd have to buy 11 scripts now we might
rewrite those extensively because we
knew the show day in and day out in a
way that the freelancers wouldn't
necessarily but that might be that first
that person's first sale it might get
them into the industry it gave so many
people chances to
get their foot in the door get a start
and and i actually ended up writing for
so many different shows because
sometimes i'd be on staff
but other times i'd just be a freelancer
coming in and pitching
and so it allowed me also to write for a
number of different shows much more so
than if i was on staff because you know
usually you're
exclusive to that show or you might be
able to write a feature when you're on
hiatus but
but on any given year any given day i
would be multitasking i got very very
good at multitasking
so i might be well like for instance
when i was a producer on sliders i was
writing my own scripts helping with
every phase of the writing on everyone
else's scripts and um but i was also i
sold to deep space nine that year and uh
far beyond the stars i had sold a
trilogy to harper collins so i was uh
starting to write the first novel with
barbara hamblin outlining the second one
with maya bonhoeff and i'd also been
hired to write all the outlines for
anamorphs and lay out that show and
write several scripts for that show so
friends so i would get into my office at
um universal at six in the morning write
an entire outline for animorphs and then
by 10 i'd be done with that i'd have
faxed it to new york and then the
sliders guys would come in and i'd do my
sliders job all day and then on the
weekend i might be working on on the
novel so uh we're on the outline for the
deep space nine episodes so it was uh
it was a great way to work because you
know how to
to to um go from one thing to another to
another without losing quality that's
that's the hugely important thing you
don't you don't ever want to be
just
providing fodder you don't you don't
want to just be writing
my friend frank spotnets who create a
man in the high castle and ran the
x-files uh he says uh good enough is
never good enough and i i agree with
that 100 percent he also says
you should every time you should aim for
the bleachers because you might at least
get a single you know and it's and and i
share that view which is give it your
best i mean you should just
everything you've got should go into
everything you do
and and if it's not good enough work
work harder you know but and sometimes
you're not going to write the great
american novel or the great american
screenplay you know one of my friends
who's uh in ohio and calls me quite
often and he said well you know that
episode of whatever show it was forever
night or whatever the that show that was
on last week wasn't up to your normal
standard why was that and i said well
you know you know how like when you're
in school and sometimes you really try
your best but you get a b on a test or a
c-plus or whatever it's sort of like
that you know you just you know it just
didn't come together and but that but it
wasn't for lack of trying you know and
so uh but that's part of it and um and
all but but again but in terms of
possibilities for the writers now
they're much greater for instance when i
started there were three networks and
pbs and so they had and they were 24 7
stations they weren't uh you couldn't
watch a show when you wanted to there
was no home video
and uh so there were only a certain
number of shows they could make just
because of the hours and a day
so it limited how many writers could get
work and it limited
the
what kind of work you could get because
if the show wasn't
approved by the network you couldn't
there's nothing you could do and if you
wanted to write something and shoot it
on your own it would cost millions of
dollars minimally
and and that was very very difficult to
raise that money now uh there's over 500
scripted comedy and drama series on the
air
on all the networks and vod platforms
and and so there's an enormous amount
more
slots for writers
additionally uh even though there isn't
freelance per se there still is
freelance in animation but not in live
action uh by and large but also people
can make their own web series they can
make their own podcasts there's so many
ways to get a following to get an
audience and um
and and i i say everyone i wouldn't go
back to any other uh period in my life
i'm i'm happiest of all now because i
have such
i have such great autonomy uh my
audience has given me over two and a
half million dollars
to open my own studio and make space
command and
and now i'm raising even more money it
turned out i had a knack and so i don't
have to ask permission from anyone i
just come up with an idea i write it i
cast it i shoot it i put it out to my my
audience around the world and
that doesn't mean that the studios and
networks and vod platforms can't be my
partners they can
but they aren't the deciding factor of
what i do in terms of what i make
i'm in terms of creatively and uh and
that's a pure joy
so going back to the 70s and then being
a freelancer yeah
completely different as to
the the tone of your day what you're
working on well it wasn't so much
different that's what i'm working on
because i was always working on shows
that i had a passion for so whether it
was sliders or even friday the 13th the
series which is story edited
i would always find the
core of it the emotional core that would
uh resonate with me
it always had to be something that i
could queue into otherwise i wouldn't
write it but and i always worked with
people who i liked and who liked me
and i was very lucky in that when this
and the studio executives and network
executives we dealt with fortunately
very supportive and very smart
and so i didn't find them intrusive
there are the other kind of executives
and and you want to try and avoid those
in in green lighting yourself i have a
section on working with stupid people
and my first piece of advice is if you
can avoid it
avoid it
but if you have to work with someone
who's in the food chain they might be
above you in the food chain here's how
you can do it and not have the work be
ruined and not have um and not be fired
and so i go into some
experiences from my career where i'm
able to walk people through that and um
but again it's
it wasn't so much
um content that was different it was
simply
it's almost like there's a difference
between performing a play if you're an
actor to an audience versus auditioning
because auditioning you need someone to
approve you in order to do your work
creatively whereas when you're in a play
performing for the audience that's the
direct relationship so the more that i
can be in the direct relationship
creatively
between the conversations between me and
the world me and my audience the better
and and really what started me on this
journey of opening my own studio and
doing crowdfunding and selling
investment shares in space command and
so forth was simply that
so many of my friends who were the
greatest writers in television had
written projects that were great and
should have become hit series and the
network or the studio cut them off at
script or cut them off at pilot the
audience never saw those great shows and
i thought you know in in books once a
novelist is relatively successful then
he can create a body of work like
stephen king for instance or
name any writer that you love and and so
they have an authorial voice and a shape
to their career that follows their
enthusiasms and what they want to talk
about at any given time but that's not
true with television writers with
television writers for the most part
they're constantly stymied from doing
they're the projects they're most
enthusiastic about or the projects that
might even be their best work because um
the studio and the networks have
different objectives which are primarily
financial objectives
and i'm and again they have a right to
do that if they're writing the checks
but now that we can go directly to our
audience and raise money that way the
fact that we can
now shoot for so much less because
digital is so much less expensive um
we can we can
change the rules to into our favor and
uh you know it used to be when when
young people would like young directors
or writers would say well i'm they're
not letting me get have my dream and i
would say well who's not letting you
have your dream they say well the
networks are the studios or whatever and
back when it cost millions of dollars to
make a movie you'd say okay well then
that makes sense they are being stymied
but now since you know they have a
camera in their pocket i don't i don't
accept that excuse anymore someone says
they're not letting me have my dream
i'll say you are um
you're using an excuse to avoid doing
the work
because the work is get a camera get
some people together get the best best
actors you can find make it happen one
way or another make it happen and
a great minute is better than a mediocre
two hours of material
but if people love it
you'll start to build your audience that
starts to build a career
how did fear of success almost ruin your
screenwriting career and when you hear
that from these these other writers yes
do you hear fear of success in their
voice or it's
it's asking for permission i think
there's always a counterweight between
fear of success and fear of failure uh
in everyone's heart in one way or
another in different measures
one is always afraid of exposure one is
always afraid of
screwing it up you know and
and ultimately you have to be willing
to
face that and get past it and get over
it and get around it you your job is to
get your work done your creative work
and with all of my mentors whether it's
rod sterling or ray bradbury or
guillermo del toro with whom i wrote a
book not long ago
i seek out mentors who are
brilliant at what they do
and then one of my key questions always
is when you encounter failure or when
you encounter rejection what do you do
and because what i'm looking for are
strategies that i can apply to my own
life in my own career that keep me
moving forward
and um
and it's been incredibly invaluable
because
you you find that the higher up someone
goes as a writer or a director or
whatever or an actor
their fear is still there
but they have coping mechanisms where
the period that they're in um
breakdown
is shorter and shorter and shorter so in
other words uh for instance when
guillermo del toro was preparing to film
his dream project the mountains of
madness based on an hp lovecraft novel
uh they pulled the plug on it universal
did because they thought it would be too
expensive and r-rated and so forth and
and guillermo had other other irons in
the fire and immediately jumped over to
pacific rim and he was off and running
so that didn't mean he didn't feel
terrible and maybe had a weekend of
feeling very sorry for himself but he
got into motion and he was already
preparing for that eventuality
eventuality in advance so that he
wouldn't be stopped and
it's very important you know i think
don't be afraid of success
because success is very nice you know
when you write a book or that's
successful or a tv show that people talk
about for decades or
you get a big payday
those things are fine they're fine i
think people are often afraid of
scrutiny they're often afraid of well
i'm a fraud and i won't be able to
handle success but success is an
extremely amorphous thing you first of
all you can define what success means to
you for instance at this point in my
life i don't need to have the million
dollar payday you know i need to keep
working creatively and getting my work
out to an audience but money is not at
all what rules me i've made choices we
still live in an apartment we own our
two cars outright you know it's
i've made choices that allow my life to
be very um
free
in that way but um but for me success is
very very clear and i'm glad that i've
been successful
you know in i mean i i you know i can
look at my career and say well clearly
i've succeeded because i've created work
that people are still talking about you
know 40 years after i did it and also
i've earned significant money writing
for the studios and the networks until
space command i'd only written for the
studios and the networks and the major
publishers i'd never
done any independent film projects and
then
you know because of this roundtable i
mentor i started hearing about
crowdfunding and
i thought well let's see if i can raise
money and turned out i could
so
even though rod sterling was considered
a
dashingly handsome confident man angry
at times maybe do you think he had a
touch of fear of success did he mask it
with or sort of the the this pretty boy
you know i don't think he was afraid of
success he was extremely charismatic
extremely confident without being
arrogant but
he felt that he had failed in his career
which is terribly sad the last interview
he gave
before he died at age 50 in in 1975
the interviewer said do you think you've
been
successful you do think you've you've
written work that will stand the test of
time and he said the good writing like
fine wine has to age well with time he
said i think my work has been
momentarily
adequate which is astonishing and so sad
that he didn't live
until now because he would have seen
that he had created one of the greatest
masterpieces of television and he had
inspired an entire generation of
showrunners i mean
every major showrunner in drama
rod is their hero he's the idol he's the
guy who sort of led the way as and um
it's really really sad that he didn't
get to uh to know that you know
i'm sure he would have been amazed and
extremely gratified
sure many other uh philip k dick
same thing fell okay dick was a
different case because he was um at
least he got to see fellow dick at least
got to see the footage from blade runner
he knew that somebody was
getting
um getting what he was doing and so he
um and he my god he created a huge
amount of work i mean he wrote i think
about 12 novels in a year plus short
stories i mean it's like let's hear from
amphetamines you know so
yes that i think that did help fuel him
but also he had his own what did he call
the hovel which was his sort of grungy
little yeah he was he was a talented man
he was very funny he was a troubled man
and there was all this whole thing of
how drugs drove him crazy and at the end
he was raving and and insane and all
that stuff and and i had dinner not long
ago with greg benford who's a fairly
conservative professor and also a
science fiction writer and i taught
we've got on the subject philip k dick
and he said oh no no phil wasn't like
that at all he was very sweet very funny
his mind was perfectly together and he
knew him you know throughout the latter
years of his life and so i was very glad
to hear that because i think sometimes
the media can get an impression of
someone which isn't accurate and philip
k dick was an amazing writer and i'm
glad that that he had friends who really
saw who he was and valued that
you